[Music]
foreign
here today we will showcase the most
powerful evil Transformers which will
include the famous Decepticons the not
so famous Predacons versions of the
primes and even got like Transformers
entities we will leave Unicron aside for
this since we all know he is Numero Uno
so let's get to it
at number 10 we have the death Soros a
deadly Decepticon deathsaurus is known
for his formidable appearance resembling
a mechanical dragon with fearsome
features he is often depicted as a large
and imposing figure with a draconing
head sharp claws and a menacing presence
he possesses immense strength durability
and combat skills making him one of the
most formidable adversaries for the
Autobots in terms of Personality he is
cutting ruthless and ambitious he is
driven by a desire for power and
Conquest constantly scheming to
overthrow its enemies and even seize
control of the power structure of the
Decepticons he is not hesitant to employ
any means necessary to achieve his goals
including manipulation and deception
and number nine we have shockwave he is
known for his goal calculating nature
and his unwavering loyalty to the
Decepticon cars Shockwave is often
portrayed as a highly intelligent and
logical character prioritizing
efficiency and strategic planning over
emotions he's considered one of the
Decepticons most reliable and powerful
warriors in many iterations of the
Transformers Universe Shockwave serves
as the decepticon's military commander
and second in command only after
Megatron visually Shockwave is
characterized by his distinctive
one-eyed design he typically transforms
into a futuristic looking Laser cannon
or a powerful tank in both modes
Shockwave possesses immense Firepower
and a skill in long-range attacks
number eight Overlord this extremely
deadly Decepticon has his Origins and
backstory varying across different
Transformers continuities just like many
others he is often depicted as a massive
robot with two distinct forms a humanoid
one and a powerful tank mode in robot
mode Overlord is a towering figure with
exceptional combat skills and incredible
physical strength he wields a variety of
weapons including swords cannons and
Powerful energy weapons making him a
formidable adversary in battle he is
often depicted as a sadistic and
merciless character reveling in
destruction and Chaos in tag mode
Overlord transforms into a heavily armed
and heavily armored vehicle this form
allows him to unleash devastating
Firepower and engage in heavy assault
during battles
number seven lockdown lockdown is often
portrayed as a tall sleek and heavily
armed robot he has a distinctive
appearance with his faceplate sharp
features and a single object eye
although in the bay verse he had a
skeletal appearance with two eyes he is
highly skilled in combat and possesses
advanced technology and weaponry one of
lockdown's defining characteristics is
that he is a bounty hunter he's known
for his ability to track down and
capture or eliminate his targets which
includes both Autobots and Decepticons
lockdown operates as a solitary
mercenary typically aligning himself
with whoever can provide the most
lucrative contracts for following his
own interests lockdown has a unique
ability to detach and reattach his body
parts in some continuities allowing him
to use his own body as a weapon
number six Scourge Scourge is the right
hand man of the powerful and tyrannical
Decepticon leader called Galvatron he is
a loyal and ruthless enforcer often
executing galvatron's orders without
question created by Unicron from a dead
decepticon's body scourge's most
recognizable feature is his ability to
transform into a Fierce and mechanical
creature called sweep the sweeps are
drawn like minions created by Unicron
the planet eating entity who transformed
Megatron into Galvatron Scourge was
among the first Transformers to be
reformatted into a sweep gaining
enhanced powers and serving as a Delhi
Army under galvatron's command he is a
very deadly decepticon and will be seen
in the upcoming movie Rise of the Beast
number five the Decepticon the
Decepticon is a colossal creature a
Transformer creature formed by combining
the bodies of numerous thousands of
Decepticons and sweeps under the
influence of the devoid it was created
during a conflict between Megatron's
Decepticon forces and Galvatron sweeps
on Cybertron to devote manipulated the
unity of the Decepticons compelling them
to merge into the Monstrous decept to
God Megatron and Shockwave managed to
resist emerging the Decepticon later
attacked the autobots and eventually
with the alliance between him and
Optimus Prime they eventually dealt it a
powerful blow later Megatron would later
learn the nature of the decepticon's
creation and use the unusual properties
of his recently upgraded body to tap
into the same energy for his own
purposes to become a god
number four Megatron slash Galvatron as
the leader of the Decepticons Megatron
typically transforms into a powerful
weapon such as a flying aircraft or a
tank or a truck symbolizing his role as
a destructive force he is depicted as a
fearsome and imposing figure inspiring
fear and loyalty among his followers the
Decepticons throughout the various
transforms media his ultimate goal is
often to conquer the universe or to
eliminate the autobots and establish the
decepticon's dominance either in just
Cybertron or the entire universe
Galvatron on the other hand is a
transformed version of Megatron in some
iterations of the Transformer storyline
Galvatron is created when Megatron
undergoes at reformulation or an upgrade
the specific circumstance surrounding
galvatron's creation vary across
different continuities but he is often
depicted as being more powerful than
Megatron
number three Predaking this is a
combiner formed by the fusion of five
Transformers known as Predacons when
they combine they merge their bodies and
Minds to become a larger entity a
towering an incredibly powerful robotic
entity called the Predaking each
protagon possesses unique strengths and
abilities which are Amplified when they
merge into Predaking as a combiner he
exhibits immense strength durability and
combat prowess and the Amplified powers
of all the five others is often
portrayed as a dominant force in a
battlefield capable of overpowering
multiple opponents with his sheer size
alone and power of course with his
commanding of other Predacons Predaking
is known for his ferocity often
displaying a Relentless and Savage
fighting style like an animal he is
often seen being bigger than most other
Transformers and possess multiple wings
as well as a large spiky whipped weapon
number two Nemesis Prime this
Transformer typically shares a similar
robot mode appearance with Optimus Prime
featuring a red and blue color scheme
however Nemesis Prime's color palette is
usually inverted or altered with the
dark or black Hues taking prominence
this gives him a more Sinister and
malevolent appearance compared to the
noble and heroic Optimus Prime he often
represents a corrupted version of the
autobot leader driven by Darkness
ambition or manipulation he generally
possesses the same physical capabilities
as Optimus Prime therefore making him
extremely powerful as a prime possessing
Superior powers to most other
Transformers
and number one the Fallen megatronus
Prime also known later as the Fallen was
originally one of the original 13 primes
a group of powerful and ancient
Transformers who played a pivotal role
in shaping the history of their world
and the universe of course however
megatronus Prime turn against the other
fellow primes and sought to cease power
for himself he became corrupted by dark
energies and embraced his role as a
malevolent and power hungry figure the
Fallen is often depicted as the central
antagonist in the Transformer stories he
is known for his ancient Origins his
desire to dominate and enslave other
civilizations the Fallen possesses
immense and ancient power often wielding
dark and destructive abilities
commanding the Decepticons with
unchallenged authority
so those are the 10 most powerful evil
Transformers ever so I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit that
like button for support and subscribe
but most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos here on
this channel take care fam